do you know if there's any effect of
solar eclipses on Wildlife well we have
had indeed uh studies on that probably
the most famous story about this
involves Thomas Edison the great
inventor he saw a total eclipse of the
Sun in Wyoming back in 1879 and he had a
a device that he was going to use to
measure the temperature of the corona
that he had just invented called the
tasm meter and he was looking around for
a place where he could set up and he saw
an old barn housee he looked around
there's nothing in there and he says oh
this is great and it'll protect me from
the wind and provide me with shelter so
he set his his instrument up and here's
totality coming it's only a few seconds
away and all of a sudden from all
directions Edison got bowled over by
chickens chickens that were coming from
all directions and going back into the
barn housee or the hen house to go to
roost because they thought that night
time was was coming that was one of the
world's great chicken stories I might
add